this photo let's go i mean it went viral
the photo of you doing the split tell me
about that
um
all it was was a reaction to
a hit piece
discussing my oversized ego on the set
and how i stretch and do clapping
push-ups and
think of myself as the cat's meow so i
thought that was that was going to be my
response and i enlisted the the crew
to help me what was that determined was
it zaddy what does that mean
one of the articles yeah yeah uh i know
an older gentleman who is uh
still
i don't know
i don't know whether i got hot i guess
that's pitch compliment yeah
well at least that's how i took it so
well then following that it said
something about your uh your ass cheeks
like a venus flytrap i said that
is that true is that do you stand by
yeah i catch flies with it
everyone's got talents no that's a great
talent tell me about the season finale
um
you know we're going to wrap things up
maybe not completely but
hopefully satisfactorily and
it was a pleasure working with dennis
leary
do you see yourself continuing to do
photos like that or any eccentric
exercises over the summer
well yeah i mean let's say you know i
gotta work it hard i just won't be
photographer photographing myself
doing it
thank you so much yeah my pleasure
you